today's generation of scientists is
tackling science and see science in
fairly substantially different ways in
the previous generation first and
foremost they are coming about at a time
where to be expert simply in one
discipline is limiting is not impossible
and is not without value but to not be
capable of connecting other disciplines
and being comfortable influence in this
new interdisciplinary landscape is it is
an inadequacy is something that would
hinder you know I think understanding
and so I think the capabilities of
thinking laterally as opposed to just
simply vertically with infield is
different I think that scientists are
also becoming more aware of their
responsibilities as citizens one of the
potential great silver linings of the
war on science in the United States over
the last seven years has been that it
has galvanized the US scientific
community in important ways and when the
ideals of science are under attack and
where scientists themselves are censored
and where freedom of flow flow of
information in a freeway is hindered and
where you know a society is making its
widely believed anti-scientific
decisions it has almost consequently led
to scientists reaffirming the core
values of being a scientist what it is
to be a scientist in fact sir david king
who's the british science advisor has
recently laid out a pretty visionary
idea of a Hippocratic oath like thing
for scientists so that all scientists
have some sort of unification some core
values that we all subscribe to so I
think that scientists now see the
connection of their work to society at
large they see how their work can be
misused and misinterpreted they see that
the funding for their research is coming
in many cases from taxpayers and so
there's a natural desire and
responsibility correlate responsibility
in the part of scientists to have
transparency and find ways of
communicating and I think that the fact
that more scientists are blogging right
now or are blogging right now are is a
sign of new ways of kind of bypassing
traditional media outlets to create this
direct communication channel with the
general public and it's allowing the
public to connect with scientists and
scientists connect with the general
public and very very very powerful ways
I think science is also a more global
enterprise today and so there is value
in being able to understand how to
connect and how to navigate across
cultures and languages and geographic
boundaries science has always been a
borderless enterprise but today more so
than ever before and when you look at a
project like the Human Genome Project
that brought together you know 29
disciplines from you know 50 plus
countries the Large Hadron Collider in
Geneva now this eight billion dollar
project which is employing half the
particle physicist in the world coming
from dozens and dozens and dozens of
nature's Nations dozens and dozens of
languages globalization has you know
permeated science and Sciences / media
globalization and so I think that
creates a new lifestyle yeah for being a
scientist so all of those things are
making scientists more
I'm engaged in global citizens